عمليه كبيره بروايه واحده يواصل المسؤولون
الاسرائيليون الحديث عن عمليه مجده دون ان
يشاركهم طرف اخر الحديث عما وقع وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي
تفقد الحدود مع لبنان وتحدث عن عمليه
كبيره وصعبه ومركبه ومعقده مشيرا في الوقت
نفسه لعدم اكتمال الوصول لتفاصيلها امتدح
جالنت دور الجيش واذرع الامن وتوعد منفذ
العمليه بالندم اريد ان اقول بشكل واضح
انما نفذ العمليه سيندم انه نفذها ضد
اسرائيل ومواطنيها لكنه قتل وفق روايه تل
ابيب ام ان جالنت يحاول توسيع اطار
العمليه الغامضه ليتعدى منفذا قتيلا الى
محرضين محتملين من نقطه مجهوله قالت
الروايه الاسرائيليه المنفرده بالقصه ان
المنفذ عبر الحدود مع لبنان بسياره حملته
سبعين كيلو مترا حتى جنوبي حيفا حيث زرع
عبوه الناسفه عند مفترق مجدو واخذ طريقه
للعوده من حيث اتى الى الحدود اللبنانيه
تتحدث روايه الاسرائيليه ايضا عما قالت
انها عمليات تفتيش واسعه قادت اخيرا الى
سياره المنفذ في بلده عراه حيث ارضي قتيلا
بسبب ارتدائه حزاما ناسفا ما زرعاه المنفذ
القتيل في مجدو انفجر وادى لاصابه اسرائيل
بجراح لكن كيف يمكن ان يعبر انسان الحدود
اللبنانيه مع اسرائيل التي تعرف بالخط
الازرق والتي ترابط عليها قوات الامم
المتحده يونيفل تلك القوات نفت علمها باي
حركه عبور للحدود من الجانب اللبناني الا
من تقارير اعلاميه ولاحقا قال المتحدث
باسمها للجزيره انهم لم يتلقوا طلبا رسميا
من اسرائيل للتحقق من وقوع تسلل حدودي
فلماذا لم تطلب اسرائيل هذا رغم انه يدعم
روايتها لو اكد الرد الاممي حدوث تسلل
الروايه الاسرائيليه المنفرده لعمليه مجدو
تاتي على وقع احتجاجات داخليه وغضب متسع
النطاق يؤرق حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو وتتهم
في سياقه بالتسبب المحتمل في انهيار
الدوله وبينما تسعى تلك الحكومه اقليميا
بجهد حفيث ليس بجديد لحصار ايران تصبح في
مواجهه تقارب وشيك بين الرياض وطهران
الحليف البارز لحزب الله اللبناني الذي لا
تخفي تل ابيب توجيه اصابع الريبه نحوه في
هذه العمليه